[Music]
later we see this shot of the full
neighborhood and unless it popped up
during the episode i'm pretty sure that
means we should see a shot of the
neighborhood here too
but also who would want to live in
spongebob's neighborhood or
squidward his oboe playing is absolutely
the worst
just kidding i know what a bassoon is
what a wonderful day assuming your day
will be wonderful after only inhaling
once
scallops are chirping scallops do not in
fact
chirp guys it's spongebob what do you
want from me here overenthusiastic and
excessively unnecessary repetition with
your tool
wait i can't work with all that going on
especially when sponge knob jerk pants
is needlessly making his work more
difficult
who tries to build a structure on top of
their supplies
assuming the saxophone has been
underwater for some time where is the
air being blown from the instrument
coming from
is squidward breathing water in storing
up the air to then push through an
instrument that needs air to make its
sound
is squidward the most advanced
underwater creature to exist having
somehow evolved to fulfill the purpose
of musical creation why is none of this
explained patrick's roof would
absolutely collapse his lamp and chair
and someone clearly hasn't been paying
attention to modern housing design
trends
what do you live under a rock
[Music]
this anteater mouth farts on for some
time
starfish do not have lungs there i said
it
capitalism spongebob is not this clever
or this much of a businessman but the
show still gets laughs from me on nearly
every episode so for this reason i will
give a sin while simultaneously taking
one away don't blink or you'll miss it
well moving on double take
three times one two three those are not
double takes
that's three single takes or at my most
generous a single triple take so
take this and pelvic thrust
unless spongebob's pelvis is in his face
this is also not a pelvic thrust
beginning to believe bob's big bubble
blowing business is basically [ __ ]
wow apparently spongebob was even more
abstract than non-sequitur when it
started
somehow which means i'll have to add
another sin for this episode but take us
in off and all the other spongebob
videos we've done which i totally just
did
seriously go watch all the other
spongebob sins vids i totally took of a
sin and this is in no way a manipulative
way to drive up views
fair warning though the sin only
disappears after the 420th consecutive
watch
see that's not squidward for not having
window panes how can you two possibly
make all this noise just blowing bubbles
come on squidward it's a cartoon quit
taking the underwater physics and
acoustics so literally
you're ruining television squidward
that's not
art that's just annoying nfts what do
you suppose this shiny quarter is made
of is it us currency that has fallen
below the surface and somehow adopted
into the undersea lifestyle of the
bikini bottom dwellers
[Music]
eruptile dysfunction technique
technique technique technique technique
i swear if you took out all the
repeating in this episode it'd be less
than 10 seconds long but also if you
took out all the repeating in this
episode it would be 10 seconds long
we have windows we have no windows
for the next full minute these two will
save the squidward 49 times each and as
much as i'd love to do a bonus round i
just don't have the energy to withstand
it again so i'll just put the 98 cents
on credit
forget understanding anything about how
this rage bubble works
yup seems like the best place to run for
safety is a massive house falls from
above would be the houses directly below
where the house is falling
this episode is 78 bubble making 13 pan
flute playing and 9
explosions happening so in each and
every way this episode blows
i'm some kind of bubble boy
what are you building for him now uh
rocket ship
and now for some soothing sounds from
squidward's clarinet
thank you thank you
[Music]
mr conrad you my friend are being
audited
but only two little ducks came
[Music]
what what'll i do what'll i do what an
unusual view